welcome back everybody to Puerto Rico's
first attack I'm jumping into tagout
Rindge because we've added one more
block this block was not going to exist
and they were like but what about all
these lovely qualifier matches for the
people at home so we're gonna be showing
every single qualifier match from now
until the top 16 that's gonna be settled
tomorrow and we have a great first one
coming up here we got Hachi Kawa from
Japan going up against the West Coast so
quick the way the camera cuts of the
headband going on was just so perfect
I'm sure so he went the handshake a fist
bump and then he dad's to counter and
Tasha controverse them to beat that that
was like a clash where like they like do
a a standing out and then he doesn't
reflect and then he does like a two in
it's got crazy
Tachi kalo rockin the mullet now dude I
said earlier on with rims and it's like
straight up a Joe Dirt haircut like it
is a straight up at Joe Dirt mullet
going on Tosh cow's head do you think he
knows what Joe Dirt is no chance there's
like zero I don't believe it for a
second
really he's so he's so nice and sincere
oh my god he's so nice and sincere you
could probably go up to and be like your
haircut reminds me of gender he's like
what is happening
silly American kupaza trash like you
know he's hilarious yeah
he played he had the wild it speaking of
yeah he's definitely a wild player a
wild dude he's hard to like hint down
and his play style into two out of three
if you're not ready I don't like your
chances it's gonna be really really
rough early hit though vataj collar yeah
I like that Kabul choice actually given
the distance from the corner good point
landing it what he would normally would
get there standing out and so point for
the two islands of the H into the super
down each leg pressure here gets the air
dash
so tuchkov was no stranger to playing
pit so Koopa playing hit he probably was
had in the match of knowledge knowing
what to look for yeah for sure I mean
something like more of a wild style so
man gets clipped whoa
so it's like a little different and like
the kind of stuff he does but I mean
having massive knowledge in general it's
so important for a catcher like this yet
something that you try to input there
when you fell down I'll go there now for
something else we're bringing Bartok
back you get the confirm like capsules
are standing out into the 2hs touch
goggles got a lot of gear here actually
to close this one out
level three I don't have to kill ya that
team go on this just came off cooldown a
little bit earlier baby could I have
expended Wow dragon reflect and try it
again
but the big whiff baby what favor punish
that but it didn't matter anyway still
got that opening took out
yeah each sense vanishes in Kansas a bag
- is the trucks assistance then
surprised I actually pull head out
considering he's pretty low alive all
right catches the tag with the light
light sure level three
yeah we'll see what the knockdown it's
gonna be after what's the mix-up yeah
it's gonna be like 100% cuz you're just
jumping back and you're just hanging out
in the air sees you here you hit see it
you just hit ass so light the counter -
it is really powerful I never back when
we saw like sonic another deal playing
hit that was one of the things that was
the most important about that character
was like you have to be on point cuz
that for him is like a free fun
snap - bring that hip back out easy
peasy that'll be my ear is the jab you
get in the background yeah it's a really
good thing bear song so Trump's left
against two characters here not a really
strong mix up character I mean he really
has to rely on getting straight hits on
the ground
three bars at the end of those dozen
span day gets hit in the air with a jump
page and tax for in the button that's
gonna do it for Game one
posh Kawa cleaners ever
[Music]
rocking this team now no longer play
freeze them no longer playing Android 18
the learn play hey
yeah no longer playing hit all these
characters have left the building
whoa he's dead he's doing like some mini
those are like the compact that so that
you can keep in your back pocket you
know wiping off the hand yeah there's
literally rust on his arcade stick
believe that story you want real deal
the junkyard and set up incoming air - 2
H legs goes low afterwards reflect that
that reflectors really important
actually to get that position otherwise
you're stuck with a lot of plus frames
hilarious - to get out of the corners
yeah double jump or opt a Candelaria is
like a really consistent escape option
if you're not scouting
change the future but you didn't expect
it to hit was actually looking for the
Block in the descending lol maybe at the
end of this obvious you called it a
spark so yeah I feel like things haven't
been that bad just fighting him sparking
there I'm kind of surprised because it
hasn't been like you know him getting
destroyed on either these games wake up
standing he'll get a lot of hits done on
change the view dresses so gonna be the
drop will see what level three he uses
yeah pick damn it
what are we going to be after o2h anyway
gotta see a snap here yeah definitely
gonna see the snap gonna bring back in
team go on give her that blue hell and
the super - connectivity it since the
fighting slash and javelin cleaned up
from Koopa nice work yeah that was a
great use of his resources that he's
still out there okay whip on the auto
drop into the hit assist on quite that
gets really high up so it's a really
useful as this for calling off my hips
like that because maybe try to attack
one burning up time up against side then
aus cleaned right if your hot shower you
have sparking and you have Yamcha which
is not like you know impossible but it's
definitely a tough past this characters
are the meter dependent so you need to
make this spark account
it's back yeah maybe the beta Sparky
Jasmine dragon rut
she's gonna have enough bars here for a
level 3 if he wants to use it
slash hip behind against the sparking
after I got choice maneuver trying slap
it's no block look like you maybe wanted
to take center I wonder if you try to Z
changing the level a little brute head 5
kick while the reflected Wendling await
your spirit bone the wolf ain't fit yeah
the only unfortunate thing is how long
the level that's the second there's more
than one unfortunate thing ain't signing
slash level 3 that was meter and you was
planning to spend anyway yet you got
dragged across upset but the thing is is
that that level 3 level 1 and a level 3
with Yamcha takes so long that you're
sparking is spent like doing the slow
spirit ball in the like a level 3 it's
so long on their side and build them to
three bottom the nth super - pretty
close yeah kind of spend the level three
I'm not quite enough yeah he's gonna
have just that little bit of hair just
like that like evened up yeah I mean
that air naps over and you got the D
blast I think he was trying to reflect
have that input on the other side so now
I'm gonna tie games the block pops
cowlick it's the c2l this is you the
drop meter this should be it bring the
drop into the spirit ball Tom 16 / top
Cour just like the Koopa add a bit
defeat like how does this happen
you can't break his spirit it's
impossible I was like alright well he
lost
he'll just shake his hand he still had
to do it I was like work I don't know
why he did it like even in defeat he was
like I can't leave the stage without
having at least seven times for no
reason like we thought it was cursed
earlier when not yelled it at the one
time did he I invested it and then
Rindge called it out and when she was
like don't dad yeah don't do it and we
just have like seven dad scuba yeah he
did a lot I don't know you can't trust
him either like he's not one of those
people if you tell him not to do it
he'll stop like he's gonna do it no
matter what the bad and defeat has such
a cool thing to do there's like you
can't break up no there's that movie
Kubo and the two strings I'm familiar
with Idol the movie kuba and the 20 tab
it was way too many I feel one is enough
I feel like one is like all right all
right we get it
that film though the kuba and the 20
dance that got a zero percent on Rotten
Tomatoes yeah there's a fortnight
tournament here so maybe he can go enter
after he's done here is I think it's a
2v2 though so
I don't even want to know that don't do
it but what's the name of it what's that
move called claw is awesome yes yeah
that's awesome that's what the kids are
doing they're flossing you should be
flossing your teeth instead instead of
playing Portland all day you should be
playing dragon ball watching on Dragon
Ball fighters and flossing your teeth
like normal humans yeah you can
literally pull up smash GG on your phone
look up the brackets right now and floss
your teeth yeah it's better for you your
dentists not attend dentists there's
always that one nine out of ten
recommend that you just flossing that's
why to be honest when I turn on the
stream I'm usually like flossing or like
you know doing like I don't know you add
these like toothpicks that are like
they're specifically made to like get
stuff out between your teeth yeah but
they're like the little little green
like for Christmas I don't know if my
roommates are listening for Christmas I
want a water pick the water picks the
dentists highly recommend those but like
why are we talking about this kid I like
usually tweeted about getting a Waterpik
and it made me think father but the
fidelity who is Puerto Rico's finest is
what everybody's been telling me is
going to be playing up lost - super noon
for Tom 16 qualifier which means
Knockhill and super noon will play for a
top of a winter slot tomorrow morning
you always hate to see the friends that
bite each other right but it happens
especially when so many of them weren't
so good we wouldn't be playing each
other for Tom eight winners but yeah
fidelity versus blue car we saw the car
earlier in pools 16 the handshake he's
too busy breathing that do the handshake
man this is so much more reserved than
what we saw on stage earlier you know
yeah we're we're also - I just want to
let everyone know we're just watching
out for you guys we're trying to make
sure that you don't come here and
somebody tells you that you have stank
breath yeah that'd be bad don't let that
happen if you come at me Oh CJ my I saw
you commentating it but I'm like I saw
it man I can't your breath smells like
to the man who earlier we saw actually
play I think
Luigi though I tried it the second game
against super named environment was
interesting is coming upwards but
definitely not and if you're that kind
of character while like player who likes
that character I think you probably
switch to this character I like poly is
it's great commands old character has
armor that's really useful good zoning
he's kind of weird and how his combos
have to operate you need the right
assist or the right team for it gets
smothered for a black baited Oh missed
on the combo that's we're up
I stopped going to the 2h they're
recording sparking I'm not even going to
go into the black yeah in the corner
there okay
trying to get away from the Delta gets
dragon breaths here gonna bring her
bring him to the sky yeah it's a slight
knockdown
okay thank you yeah yeah air blocks the
man as well so was pretty blah extension
here while resettlement ground into the
dragon rush at four bars here go right
into the level three yeah not to kill
I'm pretty good spot after preserves
lost a lot of life can force into
sparking or nods empty low on the whip
battle to it make quick work there a
Frieza already got character
yeah and if you're gonna spend sparking
early you need to make sure you get
first floor oh yeah cuz you have to
adjust the flies spending such an
important resource to survive like a
defensive situation or like you know
build a lot of meter nice
ates there
okay sparking here from double bananas
yeah let's for the auto car phone 6mm
and no air - cancel I'm not surprised
was not protecting himself best super -
there got blown up for it it's light
knockdown
the corner is kind of here against the
Dell I represent her but you know whose
name that the jump like the cross up
legs will just grab you yeah and all the
way that but like just like you know
Paul says jump like make you flinch and
then get
it's really really good to write like so
it Stephanie a scary character when she
has the SIS especially like you know I
like the 16 assists for the long time -
not as much as it used to be but it's a
pretty solid option I think for her I
agree
kids are gonna try on extensions here
blocks the 6m blocks there - pressure
yeah there's a lot of really patient
defense here going on I like what I see
but she gets a happy birthday outfit old
characters
yeah just mash or maybe a level-3 on GT
about their attack two texts in a row
reflects level-3 I don't even know if
that was on purpose me run under super
NASA
[Applause]
dragon Raj if that doesn't kill level
once you see it yeah I think the good
part about that for Lucar is that was a
great fun it's like running under and
getting the super dance a lot of people
kind of freeze up there and kind of
super dive right into it or like you
reflect it or something you got to make
sure that you're ready because on you
know that happens for whatever reason
gotta be prepared these breaks again
from fidelity illnesses seem to miss
their state with 16 assists
Oh what four to eight there but a whip
stop punished with the Qibla from
Brawley gets a side swap
yeah I gotta be the drum into the van
and that's gonna be death therefore Goku
finally got a character down off of Luke
our side
there's the dragon rush finally knock
knock
finally got the head to bars to kill
level one that'll do it
Luger up first point it's something I
mean in that position you know breaking
all those dragon rushes is not easy five
six in a row
eventually you'll slip and the one you
do is go on the matter bark the 6mm air
- over I'm back this time calls of
analysis whip on the air bro - super -
in go clear sense and that's it
Oh banished nice dad during that Brandt
well you see the armor coming out from
Crawley you can vanish and get to the
other side and you're not too worried
about you know getting hit by like harm
or a lariat or whatever vanish for the
pickup there they're sliding on
[Music]
it's an air 2/8 there that was jump and
then air to aid for oh yeah that we
enjoys yeah you know Lake flip there
it's so good who's gonna like duck what
do you see a character go up in the air
is not like a job can you see most
people do I like that
Fidel ease didn't just tack on her way
right like didn't panic tang out Frieza
yeah you know 284 clients are ready for
gonna be the snap rephrase that with no
life you got a rep for Alpha Delta
players here he has the witness
I'll get split the overhead and in the
corner the air - for the pickup you get
that light light light that's gonna be
one character down here breeze out of
the way JC go through a burly to deal
with the blue car wants to move on three
all the time
the bowler
sign up here here - over miss on the
jump-out also not too tough to block
right under it that goes right into the
dragon Russ you did not take that knock
down lotta Peter
level one level three sparking available
on the dog down here so we'll see what
the choices on wake up despite the
nerves to it right yeah for sure
I mean smart gonna wake up it's gonna be
the call out blue carpet challenge since
parking away comes negative but help
vanishes over the good option out there
fart sound rockin pissed
hold the van in a double vanish that's
two meters then dragon rush note break
look at the meter build with sparking
wow three bars air yet three bars on
deck this could be it
so we're just gonna go to lunch
Yanis ago one
for easy previously so fidelity down the
solo Brawley again I mean the nice thing
is that Vidal is like one good hint from
dying so it's 16 go-go's got a lot of
life oh yeah I'm gonna try to extent no
that was a reset attempt trying to catch
an uptick with the air bro that's an
interesting idea we I think I saw that
same setup earlier nice the key blast
kills okay so that's all three meters
spent by weren't them to get the kill
you
[Music]
Oh super - look Chris has been chipping
away with the super arrow with the ice
dragon marshal we've seen so many
trying to wait for that magellan sis to
come up I see you yeah just keep this a
all the reflects yeah there was no
punish on that all the barrier jumps in
second Head dragon rush
like the jump in medium into the light
into the dragon rush
level one level three change it if not
it's like a pixel yeah the power of love
is enough moving on in the top 16 losers
bracket
what's love got to do got to do it have
to do with everything everything yeah
for those two absolutely take the thumbs
up PR the crowd goes wild
no one's excited about that that's their
boy losing on state blue card definitely
earn that win there yeah and you know
what's funny is like I'm looking at the
losers bracket now and I see the next
match we're gonna have here is gonna be
wah wah versus neo vermilion and I got
to tell you if you're in the loser's
bracket of this tournament top 32 you
don't expect to run into wall walk like
of all people you're like oh I've been
loser side you know see if I can make it
to top 16 Luke wall one like that early
yeah it's like I got to play wall on top
stop thirty-two loser bracket but now
he'll showed up played fantastic right
so I was really impressed with his play
earlier you can tell that he really
recognized that wah wah was not gonna
challenge a lot on defense so just like
overstayed his welcome on every
offensive series and kind of broke him
down so I was very impressed obviously
one of the world's finest racquetball
players you know in the conversation
always with sonic with Joey Chi with you
know fen rich that's like one of the top
dragon ball players and at the very top
of the leaderboards currently for the
dragon ball poor obviously out here to
play and get some matches and doesn't
really need the points by any means but
maybe he's looking for seating or
something so good old naki ol from
Seattle by way of New York
Walla couldn't handle the return of the
snack yeah he was ready he looked great
honestly you know when nakiye is playing
like nokia he's very hard to beat but
there's always those times in tournament
where he's dropping stuff where he's not
hitting things like when he's playing
very off the moldings a tough tough man
to beat I mean he could be any of you
know anybody right including someone
like wah wah he is
Gohan dominance so far that Wallace
switched to Bardock yeah I mean that's
the thing about what wala that's
interesting right is he has like a
rotation of point characters he runs so
I'm a big wall a fan I'm a big yeah yeah
his go on even though he lost the game
then he ended up switching him out he
did really well in the game with him I
don't I don't believe in the switch
because the second rough it was rough
yeah the second game was rough I was
like remembering the second game but
then I it was like hard to remember it
because it was a path I was like man I
wonder if the over million no scrap
Vermillion you know that I was thinking
the same thing when I saw the vermilion
pack earlier I was like they all drew
millions know each other day that is a
lot of water a family yeah yeah is a lot
of water stay hydrated my friend it's a
yeah out here it's important I should
drink some water right now I'm gonna
drink some water
what's the hydro bottom stay hydrated
bomb yes they hydrated 9 if you've been
watching for 10 minutes you supposed to
drink 19 gallons of why it's like some
of the servile one make sure you have a
bathroom nearby no uh go on right so we
see base Goku GZ Goku Super Saiyan Goku
for wahwah yeah he kind of rotates
around what character he plays it you
know depending on the matchup depending
on the player I think
yeah to be honest in general I love his
Space Ghost right I think this character
is fantastic
he's really a specialist with this
character and you can see the work for
this character really put in for sure
this is I mean the Michelle characters
he uses though they need to go through
and Super Saiyan Goku you can't really
go wrong they're really good support for
any strong one character that you have
yeah he's going right in already to the
genki-dama as you would say look at
those boilers the collar he's bossing
for sure and not like how the kids do
free jump combo here super - land get
the double jump built as much meter as
he could level one make work work we're
barely into this first game enough
characters aren't you dead I can't tell
you I would not want to play wall with
this early losses right like you said we
see the name wall on to losers bracket
here just beats in your heart yeah I got
I got I wonder we're gonna see a
sparking soon the air - was good didn't
use a pickup off then and there's the
spark out the assists were about to come
back
yeah a great prediction there any
extension on Facebook ooh a really good
extension that's not easy to do that
assist is like really good if you hate
it but yeah you got to make sure you're
ready for it
it's off the dragon flat fist that we
saw from the air
[Music]
[Music]
another dama here yeah I think you're
right here we go
raise your hand up yeah don't fix it if
it's not broken right I mean it it's
pretty good setup nothing better to
reflect
probably smart but wasn't [ __ ] second
floor so hit that low I'm gonna secure
this debt only could boomer mate yeah
it's looking pretty clinical so far for
a while
honestly
they have a million with no sparking no
characters for backup Wawa's dogs
barking air - cats is the ML gonna hit
the corner yeah I mean this is one of
the finest right right now at
racquetball he's such a talented player
this is a tough person to run into yet
so far while we're showing why he's one
of the world's best if you ever wanted
to stress somebody how it will keep you
haven't your characters almost all gone
right now but neo
million stop making use of what
resources he has up its level three yeah
you got slips on that Peter you need to
build it back so spark up from Wawa
I like that choice balls easy peasy Wawa
execution 10 out of 10 gonna clean it up
first game an excellently play yeah with
no sparking there there there was no way
to save yourself too bad yeah so man
that is a younger that is the Wonder kid
Wawa on the stage all the way out France
showing why you know he's being some of
the best in this game already extension
here slide knockdown dragon Russ
clinical it's the exact same thing we
saw last on the snap on the Opera in the
loan as well same scenario
we jump combo both this is available
yeah same thing spent Botha says Oh miss
it yeah wow this but it's wall on so how
long is he gonna really remain in this
corner yeah plus frames just blocks it
out well the side trying to dragon right
actually yeah that will fake miss Carter
okay going into the other one minute to
go punished for that five bars on deck
for Wawa
yeah I'm gonna get the drop stand in the
auto proper this time the level room
no mrs. Levin escape edala Danny yes
poor Peter to dump on this to actually
dragon rush in the air
level one seven bar combo no.6 I love at
the end where he picks him up - he's
like you ko can and just draw up some
just that little the little wrist flick
is all it takes
cleaned up so while we'll let you drink
first thought we've seen the space
doctor so far it's been all the beauty
gonna show I mean would you ever have it
any other way say again 50 go-go-go
ghost is on the screen show I want to
see his face coach I want to see the
tick yeah it's very good - an extension
to the auto kampala yeah bad spot to be
I think the spark out with good idea
super monitor nice walk in the air
that's over
still gonna take my network Vince though
despite not sparking not a lot of beer
here on me over million sign gets blown
up fight yeah five switch missed the
combo just attack the Powerball over
stop me on Bihar and that is a big hit
in fact the kill I love the movements
that we just saw from Wawa whether it
was hit backing off or him knowing when
to assert himself back yeah that's clean
I mean especially like he called the
assist and then just backed off and then
once this is here ran out paint the firm
don't put yourself at a rest
corner extension both us and oh we miss
it that's unfortunate that's second time
he's missed a spirit bomb in this yeah
that was the kill I mean it's it's not
looking like it's gonna be
[Applause]
he just gets the hit that theme is just
so good this is the kill very very
clinical stay here for a while
moving on top 16 losers bracket the ko
can you know what's funny is he doesn't
even look happy he looks like he's ready
to play top 16 right back he's always
looks like that yeah you know it looks
kind of like a music yeah yeah I guess
that's really happy inside though you
got a magic
it's like sage earlier where I asked him
he's like it's my face you know he's
like I'm kind of you know I'm just sort
of like this all the time if you like
that yeah very good player so I'm
excited to see it's crazy to me because
earlier I was saying like I think
there's gonna be an EU tournament
probably an ant like any winners finally
Orsi shanked wah-wah out there and stuff
they're both losers bracket I know like
you're us players I did like the reverse
I was like yeah dude Europe's got this
and then like the u.s. players beat them
and I was like what after you curse them
I unintentionally curse them into losers
bracket but to be fair that doesn't mean
they can't win out of losers right a bit
and unless I just hate to be an it so
I'm already making fun of the I can't
understand a word these people from
London say they call everybody rude boys
and man demand waste men and the ting
you were you were saying - Logan sama
earlier you were saying to him like
maybe they just can make up words on the
spot like Jared it's just made up like
if I said any of those words and my
accent people would think I'm crazy but
because of their accent they get away
with it
shout-out to the broths yeah like what I
had shoutouts to the brats I say bro a
lot so I can't hate on bro
I started st. bro before I knew them
because I watched the Kingsmen movie
yeah and bro bro to me like brah it's
just such a good like you know with
something when a super - goes the wrong
way you just say bro
like it's such a good look bro it just
feels good when you have to be it gives
you like you know it's like pinkies out
yes it's like the pinkies out it's like
upgrading to like almond milk I see yeah
yeah oh man that was a good analogy I
like yeah we're upgrading to home and OH
got to keep it real here that's all we
can't do and we got our m-z being sent
here to losers I believe it was to kill
sage okay I was gonna say I know it
wasn't super noon or sub or not kill so
I was like it must be one of the other
players in the top 16 qualifiers that I
missed
speaking of sage he's running around
past us right now walking until the
matches he looks great
I told him I saw man you look then you
lost weight yeah oh this guy's shaking
some other guy's hand
he's deflate sage yeah he's that he's
definitely a little fella compared to
what he used to be all right sat down
ready to go music on new Kanye album so
I this must have been a match that you
commentated if it was on stream
I've not seen lung stir yet I've seen
longest ER yeah he was on earlier I'm
trying to think I'm trying remember who
I saw him lose - oh no he he made it now
loser side - what's his name he's
probably playing honey badger honey
badger Ruth in top 30 - losers he's
gonna play later on so yeah I think he'd
lost honey badger to make it on a winter
side and then now while the loser side
has he not even turned on his controller
yet back here was super noon sent to
losers ah that's yeah that's that's who
noon just Central losers
so yes super noon is gonna be playing up
against no key oh I think about the top
a qualifier and I think the other one
must be sage versus sub subatomic as we
sent shanks to losers very good to look
forward to but also you know we still
got to see big but Jackson again did it
oh man I forgot wait for that rinji was
tight we had big but jackson Icaza
legend what eight it's a name to commit
to you for the rest of your life like
everywhere you go you have to be like
hey it's me big putt Jackson it's gonna
look at the bracket cuz I realize that
although I was thinking about the
matches that are coming up there's still
a lot of players in winter side actually
so some of the matches I thought might
be coming up might not be his I forgot
posh cow was still in there and I forgot
that likes their sub but there's like a
few other players that I wasn't looking
at so I'm not look at the crackhead in a
second you guys can find all that come
on smash da GG in the meantime look like
these intro G yeah smash DG on mobile
everybody's favorite website
not going at the dramatic intro because
we're on a different stage here but
that's true yeah wow that was a queen
air - over man and they're gonna get the
reed jump no missed it down tech auto
combo Bardock literally on the light
line
latigo push this going for the lung
there yeah lungs is in a bathtub weird
wrong this is the first potato
yeah that's true I'm actually a
character that was once very popular and
if you look here we probably see them
too that's truth to be out the triangle
Russ hated by the assist I like that a
large house six meters to get the kill
here barring any drops think that
yeah not enough but the energy field to
do it
[Music]
oh actually we saw that a couple of
times from lung stirrer there to me the
heart with how strong he played till
Satan's party out of character yeah play
some solid neutral here but gets hit in
the air to air yeah an air jump lol lol
confirm nice that was a good air confirm
their smash instead of taking like you
know a lot of people there just do a
chin to vanish and then they lose a lot
of damage lose the corner easy-peasy
that's the kill so we're tied up here
similar in life both the sparking
those are coming on my hog something
after jumps back gets hit in the air
level three ago yeah right into that
level three
yeah help me sell that again six minutes
or no fans cells in the yard again
going through the garbage
yeah it's adventure you know that goes
that boy sell again clean is yeah man
sparking still available
yeah wicked buttons I think probably
trying to make this bar okay
oh okay goes right to the dragon brush
they're gonna try and make your work and
get rid of this team go on at his Auto
Bravo those into the final flashing here
there was a bus it got like ears maybe
two patches ago like it knocked down
[Music]
a nautical to get the kill nice words
you get up here both on sparking yeah
the most important part here is like
who's ready for a super - for an
air-to-air right those are the two main
things you have to watch out for like
the jump for it now like that is looking
for an air-to-air also like I always
feel like when we deliver screen you
also gotta worry about him doing the
flash like the leg kick are all the
rocket rocket kick that'll catch you a
lot slipping too if you think you're
going to open up and get the break in
that sparks up yeah I think that was a
weird spot didn't trust the way that
makes up was looking to H oh I thought
you were gonna counter to age
good place from the beer yeah drop it a
lot of that business great setup
oh just beat us out to H there's the
block air dash over nice block again I
thought that was a 2h or a DP wait but
the clean super - on the key blasts nice
and easy
yeah that was great you know
that was great effect and notice that
opportunity and just sees it so we're
going into the next game yeah you know
what's funny is that like we sought to
go untie so early last my party right
and it didn't even send a battery too
much anyway I think about yeah Bartok
I'm one of his hair - styling right in
the beginning the Super Saiyan Vegeta
and then as I didn't even matter
it's Kim long gonna take the snap
Paul I wonder what that was that was
definitely not what he tried to do maybe
he just missed the fuzzy
they put the other self layer image that
was in France today
that was like Stokes most hidden dragon
rush between the key blasts I've ever
seen
that's how about B sometimes yeah that
was like I can't believe that assistant
now put him in blossom old tractor for
engine rush devil that Sparky is gonna
deny it that opportunity
go up with the help banister
good question
I feel like you just got stuck stuck in
the lights
[Music]
ruff elected but in the front dragon
ruff
first blood a cell goes down still
hobbies you know sparking for the the
first kill very common trade that we see
super down in drops Mocambo
all right Goku black and sisters gone
and out of there if something back teams
don't want that much that gets the
dragon brush here yeah four meters to
which is pretty big three beautiful
that's the kill taste divine fury
[Music]
all right both players to two
lustre definitely having the advantage
of sparking but the meter again if you
are at each side
[Music]
it's pretty good to be even spending
that extra meter takes the snap
I think maybe to be it in an air
uppercut or he was afraid of sparking
it's like pretty patient when he got on
to H and next a lot of meter too
[Music]
it's got funny knockdown created but
yeah I mean not really much else you can
do
that's right choice make my thing Oh
we'll see what the Okies gonna be for
the well
let's back out of there so where you
tried it - hmm - Lori yeah just a little
bit
[Music]
yeah yes we are as much as you can try
it like it's not gonna kill that's fine
okay I like going out there to find that
yeah you teleport on the Fri hit the age
Oh Marty look that I was like nice oh
good
give the nod to Sloane
[Music]
get the key bandage across the screen
take them into the corner
yeah grounded level three half of the
legs
after goes for the jump in yeah yes
fortunate thing is like 6m with notes
bar and no assists its life you know
jumps the commando you try that twice in
a row yeah I think the commando is good
to bring out but the problem is going to
do it back to back
it's like pressure on the mind you know
you just jump out of that last command
low so you ready for another one yeah
ready for it
rmz looking to take this game to here
yeah whoa no looking solid here that's a
crazy break out a really far dragon rush
as he was landing still ready for it
Kharma there should be the kill I
definitely think you're right well that
cause I'm not sure the vanish gets the
job done
top 16 losers I always feel like when
vanishes kill it's like the online
special I feel like that's like the last
little bit like you're you're feeling I
mean that wasn't random but like most of
the time like if you really need to
close something out get that get that
vanish in boom yeah the thing is that's
interesting about like throwing out
vanish it's like if they counter vanish
your vanish and you have like a lead or
something it's actually really good like
you're like great I'll just like make
you waste meter or whatever like oh
that's awesome I got down for it
in that case like it was like a vanished
starter into a vanish at the end I
wasn't gonna leave that anything I was
just like I need this to kill and it was
the last little bit I thought he was
gonna do like the two em on the ground
and they're like a loop but he just did
Auto combo and then problems the air and
I was like then it'd be really close so
yeah that acts a little head on the
Vantage help nice work the van was a
smart way to close it out and up next
hopefully it's not the last time we see
him but I know a lot of people are gonna
be cheering for our other person as well
here we got shanks versus Alucard this
is fire new york like two favorites
right yeah it's like two people that two
players that people love to watch I know
that all of Spain no matter the time
zone they're in the champ hosting the
Spanish flags cheering on shanks like if
he wins like I he wins the saga there
they're gonna have like a parade I'm
sure they'll be like a parade in his
honor
yeah it'll be like a holiday they're
gonna bang all right Spain we're gonna
close close down Madrid for the day it's
just National shanks they help Padre day
everybody just like you know this is it
so yeah because Alucard another fan
favorite streams plays lot if you watch
any the New York sessions is always
playing dragon ball yeah subatomic you
know he was playing really strong when
he sent shanks to losers and shanks just
couldn't handle a lot of those like the
screams like the Yelp cancels he was he
was falling victim to a lot of those
against subatomic sabers you know what's
interesting too is that like some sub
has played that team for a long time
right and that team he used to be really
good right like there's a time where
vegeta cell vegeto cell and go tanks was
like a super like mad a team but then it
fell off and since then i feel like a
lot of people haven't played against
those characters as much and I think
people are maybe not as familiar with
that game plan but like that's always
been his team you know that's like who
he plays who the characters he likes to
play and sub is so good right like it's
it's really fun to see him like you know
playing up against guys like shanks and
just showing how good he is right it's
funny cuz he'll show the wins and I
fight then he'll get like third right
seeing him evolves oh yeah feel like I
feel like one of my first times
commentating a match of his was that
comma breaker breaker yeah and just
seeing his evolution and him being
consist
in like these top no placements since
then you know he's come a very long way
yeah but we're getting into this
unfortunately he sent shanks to losers
but here's shanks chance to redeem
himself or Alec arts chance to redeem
himself here we got two Nimba on the
screen Android 18 yeah these are two fun
teams foot players to watch right like
they both play pretty cool squads and
their fan favorites right people love
watching
Alec Ross Frieza and genève I guess -
right and also people just root for
shanks all time he's such an exciting
player watch really really fun Blair and
cool guys so this should be a pretty
good match I think early teleport that's
one thing about Jenner but for fair ride
is like you know if you are not
challenging the teleports I think it's
not so bad you can just kind of up back
and like you like okay what is he gonna
do is he actually commits an offense as
well with one number reflect early yeah
there's a flight for smart choice can
make you be super - gear on and ready
for punch for the knockdown pair your
wake up in the dvss that is so good
extended knock down here to the corner
ok the assist with 17 is out so you
cannot call in that gets the low because
of it that is such a it just puts the
fear in you're right okay
just me against this carrot girl well
you know I'll see what its gonna be and
that's to kill early
gets the level up for Gohan what I love
too about shanks you so that is I feel
like Shane use the internet team that
really put that assist on the market
we've had other tops and ready-to-eat
players right we had to kill stay for a
while player we had talked to Paola and
either them use that as much as shake
stuff
yeah a lot it's really good you can see
why that good magic knowledge to reflect
right down on basketball
[Music]
yeah and it's use the barrier assist is
what a world Fox right it's so useful in
situations where you should have the
ability to press but then suddenly like
wait a minute why am I getting hit and
then you realize that really clean
barrier is this all that the [ __ ] wow
that's a lay on that bandage too just to
get that met yeah that's a real real bad
you know if you're Alucard while you're
draggin rush is happening you're like oh
god no because you know you're dead and
you know like it's just over you've
built 3-4 meters from that right like
super music meter positive ending at the
kill yeah that was like a free punch
like it's not like you know it's super
complicated confirmed like you just
health advantage air that's it do your
favorite B&B yeah off this Jenks has a
really good sparking bait as well with
17 assists so we'll see if that's what
the party mates gonna be okay just goes
in for the Arab good patience there
prowl is hardening calling it that
every 18 level 3 that used to be like an
automatic guarantee they're probably
gonna smart before understood and it
still just so good yeah yeah exactly it
used to be so much better it's still
fair you fell on to the low yeah was
looking to block the second bit at the
17 assists you know hit the ground early
extension FEMA says dragon rush command
throw stomp level 1 level 1 that's heavy
very strong game one here from el padre
yeah clean as ever
Alucard you know that early kill really
like icing you know the rest of his team
kinda was on the back foot the whole
time and the GG T Goku not a lot of room
to wiggle when he's serving up with that
first game is straight way go that's
true
you know I got to imagine there's if the
chat room has I don't how many viewers
are but if you take how many viewers
there are and then like - that buy one
that's how many people in the chat or
from Spain rooting for shanks it's
always the entire chat room hosting
Spanish flags like the entire time and
then Damascus is in there posted in the
Spanish flag and I'm like you know what
I can respect that that's like that's
fair enough
right France already has like be a
strike ball players so I don't blame you
they are animals they're so good in the
best way
- I want to go to Spain Spain that seems
like a cool place like actually that was
really good patience to know that the
actual yeah oh you could have stayed on
the ground in the send email I think
maybe this yeah didn't respect it but
twice didn't get the call office
great change into Super Saiyan Goku here
yeah this is a bow knockdown
we didn't really see this character
shanxi honest very racist eats up close
of the freezer projectiles double-talk
to avoid the dis
I like the patients here from Shane
trying to make sure that he respects the
beads that breed the first out yeah you
can't get to answer here against Brees
otherwise you kind of get snapped up
calls the 18 assists
oh you're clean yeah that was a really
clean babe
extension this is enough to kill that's
a big prefer it's always a win when you
can level up going on yep yeah that
level watered right I mean that
alternative is use one or threes right
but you either take the level threes or
you want the level one so you can yell
it off and you know all the bucks to let
your humbles a better fastball
[Music]
yeah bill 3-meter
one level on top of another
easy easy yeah thanks looks great and is
sitting on sparking as well yeah it's
bargaining is so pretty strong force to
be reckoned with
it's just can't Allan burns me back from
this it's hit over the head with the
jump heavy into the Gowanus yeah
dang you got the heart fumble through
the extension with the key block and
another level up on Gohan yeah jumps
back if Alucard gets in here he's dead
for sure shanks will spark up okay
sparks out blocks done I like that idea
hold the vanish
[Music]
or the punish on that the 2h
yeah sister come to age again thanks
ready yeah super after the combo elbow
drop here sparks up built the fourth
meter both at the double number one one
one that's gonna be all four beers
that's the kill beautifully done from
shanks
unfortunately sending them home that's
all positive and he's so good it's such
a good player team losers side moving on
we'll see him tomorrow
one of the best players in the world for
sure right so I'm very impressed that
not only is he moving on but that he's
in looser side that just shows you the
level of competition we have here right
the fact that he's losing side of the
bracket it's like shanks is and losers
what who beat him well when I was saying
that he's one of those players where he
on it's unfortunate like I'd like to see
him on the winners side but he is no
stranger to making top eight multiple
times on the loser side yeah and I will
Knox plain about seeing more subatomic
sabers he's a fantastic player you West
Coast boys to be fair he's just that
good right to beat shanks you got to be
good I'm gonna double I shanked like
part of the East Coast because you're
playing there East there East Spain
Spain as me familia no he's New York
like if anybody claims up New York
claims them because that's what New York
does yeah and all the people in the
channel I'm hosting Spanish flags I
support you thanks for tuning in of
course to first attack here in Puerto
Rico we're gonna take a short break when
we come back we'll be having the last
little bit of top 16 losers qualifier so
see you guys in just a little bit
turn of events I can't believe condemn
who actually blocked this 6m after that
2l right the - well overhead usually
goes with to em after trying to catch
you low but a nice scramble and
recognization to get that hit confirm
still in the corner dunk dismantle Isaac
competes in the part up the light light
from can devil that's going to swim to
ties back in his favor he's gonna take
him all the way back to the other side
scramble though he's been so good in it
despite base and sonic pops him back in
you get that for 305mm oh the air is
don't try to sneak behind me this is
such a creep tune from people well you
can't take an IQ plays 20 books and yes
he's down
have a seat you're in timeout mister
yeah that level three freezes the region
for quite some time it's great against
the sparking all to jump back to find yo
Sonic's box he's over character right
now can devil aggravated this parking
Israel
a lot better sacrifice for the head in
that last one all that was looking for
the 20 frames you want to check on the
ground I will hit you low if you're
gonna block your doll and you are dead
because of it go hit the streets the
buff send them back down vans ball
they'll follow up
sonic pops man this game is looking a
lot better the easiest car to deal with
obviously does very much keep the
pressure going by himself
yes my boys on top ever completely safe
we talked about how Google team see I
mean in a 1 V 3 scenario it definitely
gets harder but still not impossible you
can have some sound play before when the
dragon was not gonna find his mark and
ever find another hit on bottoms
fadeaway
six boys got a lot
all the challenge right now is level
three phony clubs evens it up saves one
much point and now offers itself one
that's gonna be game five in the world
bro he was so many steps ahead at the
beginning of that last fight right we
saw him use the HS super one here to
maintain the corner bag - for the
perfect sparking bait spacing level 3
that's the sonic Fox I want to see block
last name as I said here moves their
goals home the first sonic Fox not able
to make anything happen from it
no meter no joke college
neat man treats lots of damage on top
over that age started gonna set up the
goals vortex and we've seen this before
how they get out of it go like that no
meter no vanish defense sonic box still
hold back the beyblade screen beam hits
no we don't care it's nothing it gets a
blue life out 16 come here
thank you yes the openings there sorry
folks pretty good trade situations not
ready gets the to 8 while the sparking
is active hit their boink control once
again so good he's gonna go from goes
from to a screen now passed over the
corner than I thought tap out give me
that blue live what a conversion it was
smoked week for too little
I was back do you think he cares about
the beyblades you're grounded
level 1 to level 1 and that's gonna be
ok
sonic fox net sparking is running out
and elbow only has two characters that
he has three bars on this side nice
bandage and he holds it I'm gonna stay
on sonic Fox needs to be careful he
wants to closes out home jumps out of
the man throw good stuff has been clean
King David rocking everything while the
bait is there that's gonna be yet
another opening for Sony forces should
be able to finish up with that Android
16 and offering himself one more
character can he do it
sacrifice cleanweave punish with the 5
mm or the best puns in the game reduce
open devil damage us tomorrow
Wow finally at the end of having no
assists Sonic's locks finally mr. dragon
rush and I take off some damage pool
boys on the corner gonna spend three of
those for the level three and then this
doesn't make a difference because you're
in the corner tail with this big sir oh
oh oh no he'll get the pickup in Sonic
even try to call the hit a system ask
him behind but he gets the cross up with
the whiff command throw with bar dog
backing it up
oh wow we tried we tried not walking get
him there is another chance that's not
back you want to make a 1 B 1 dragon
rush sonic Fox not ready three bars on
the side again devil gets the fourth
okay so - up level three like this which
is ever gonna put a hit on medical
support
oh now I see key went behind and that's
gonna even away Shaikh [ __ ] gonna take
your kidney and qualify stays alive one
more for America
what up everybody welcome back to first
tank here we in our final hour it's
gonna be all of the matches to see who
is qualified for top 16 it is ten hours
past when we started today well nine and
some change but it will be 10 hours by
the time we finish here
and we'll be wrapping up to see who's
gonna be playing in the top 16 tomorrow
if you got a smash GG look up first
attack it's on the future tournaments if
you scroll on there you can see the
bracket for tomorrow we got the top 16
bracket locked and loaded for winter
side and we're now wrapping up all the
losers qualifier matches so that's
what's coming up now as we see Lord
night versus honey badger yeah and we
saw him earlier plot the Bardock
headband yeah he does the bandanna every
time like he always ties the bandanna
and he synchronized the tie on the back
with part off finishing so he's doing
you know he's doing a little bit of a
cosplay kind of I guess it's the hidden
cosplay yeah it's like the egg warmers
like yeah the Richard Simmons like
nineties like warmer things thank God I
mean that yeah that Bartok house he
definitely dresses like a workout video
character yeah what's the call on me
have you ever seen the music video for
that song in like the like one-piece
outfits with like the high like leg
warmers yeah I don't imagine that that
outfit is actually very warm right no
I'm going next weekend and I was like as
a hostile citrus like it's gonna be like
20 degrees so I was like you should
bring a coat and a scarf okay and
probably some gloves I think I don't
like two out of three of those things
yeah I guess I guess we wouldn't need
that much living in California it's like
70 in our winter it's like a frigid 60
degrees you know I'm actually glad that
even in Atlanta even though we don't get
a super cold winter and you know right
they they didn't get snow last year when
I was there like made a little dust but
like for the most part like it'll get a
little chilly but you know not so chilly
here we go here we go man
tied up I love it
I'm a long hair - all right all I need
to see is where's the elk a Super Saiyan
keeping its composure you don't care
it'll be really tight take this he just
screamed like he was going super saiyan
hydrides to go on team - oh boy that's
the reason why this character is really
really strong pressure but you can
already see the auto combo people gets
really good for dealing with situations
like that where characters blow up in
the air or above you're anything like
that no air two agents then just get the
vanish confirmed and drop yeah I think
not getting air - aids into the corner
and then missing the combo it's like a
double whammy for worst situation you
can have but this is the kill anyway for
out there yeah I think he was trying to
get that assist with invert 21 there and
it didn't work out for him so he got hit
yeah quick kill
okay early early kill man that part off
all that worth putting on the bandana
hence the dead
you know he might have might have ruined
it pumps out there but here we go
one thing she does she has really good
air ki blasts yeah forgive us general
saw it and that big tail that jump down
that we see getting the air to air
they're picking the quarter expended
with the both Lewis's yeah there we go
gonna banish
yeah we're gonna close for the load on
the phone yeah that's one of those like
you believe in your opponent's defense
right so you're like okay 200 and then
I'm gonna go for the overhead and their
weight you got hit and it's already too
late to change your mind we're great
reflect oh it's hit from the air yeah
greater there Oh Rob extension there but
not quite working out that way on level
one keep laughs holds the vanish bottle
combo
that's pretty safe yeah cause he was
trying to look and see if honey badger
was gonna go for the two H which is
exactly what I end up getting it by any
way hotter combo seven meters some
pretty swag stuff to her I'm sure we're
gonna see ya again
we'll try to go with the flash there
yeah no buttons from out there we're us
got me on the ha completely out of the
corner since you get to choose what
direction you go ahead and stop you do
it
forget to go get these man crab
yeah the super NASA to pick a bathroom
seven meters we just snap after snap
there's the level three gonna get okie
off this some pretty good okey she
doesn't like that tart throw it away
there it is too heavy
no way now LK was committed to it level
one put that kill and you know what's
funny is like we saw the early kill but
after that honey badger
that's just gotten like five or six
clean hits back-to-back back look at how
okay steam right no sparking lamps I
have life on both of his characters you
know he dumps the BART off game but I
feel like his character is the Android
21 something start bringing tasty treats
for his intro fire harder to bring in
than a headband but it it's bright
better her that's the way he's been
playing I jump back and super useful
wall to just like keep people out and if
you're out okay I think you have to
change your approach a little bit on the
air so you don't get hit by oh wow super
Dan put some yeah that cross up a three
bars here
can't spend it yeah going to the level
three okay with a lot of meter but not a
lot of life for this GT Goku I mean even
as a super psycho good to be honest I
think you thought he was gonna dance
forward and uses magic vanish on defense
yeah and all like this LK not like this
that's a big loss right there to not
have G to go through no assist lab we
got some staggers on Android 21 is that
a fact I think LK was trying to snipe at
me with a jump a dare or something
dragon rush this is big not to kill not
to tell gonna have a great setup after
this we're going for a jump media will
you run up fake props up or something
downward kamehameha kills that was good
that was that was a really good mix up
situation put himself in the front jump
fake like who's gonna here - over that's
a setup I see okay heavy is gonna close
it out here
Puerto Rico is excited just like a
last-second LK up back got clipped out
of that that was a little scary that was
he was supposed to be dead a long long
time before that
she's standing out at the start from
alkane maybe looking for something
around there in Auto complex we will
almost confirmed often that load looks
for the 2m jumps out
Bardock we didn't really get see this
care to play very much lap on two out
far yeah the patient's here right now my
father is like a whole different change
of momentum-- salami
[Music]
we'll see the pressure is jump a
yeah there's a reflect I was gonna say
no reflect on the assist what's been
really good two of the staggers
they cook the assist versed in mid-table
are not level three after the alkane
special here that level three soon as
you got it which teen gohan goes for the
ft jump low yeah get the legs to l8
super - both assist available for
extension not the kill and the spark at
a key part off alive be careful here it
does have GT go to assist but now it's
down
unzip the super gas on him yeah this
appears you spent sparking to keep this
character alive you need this him right
this is a four level three that's it
probably gonna force the sparking if LK
doesn't want to have to do any kind of
mix-up after this
yeah that's back that was definitely a
spark eBay and LK with the good breed
goes for the tag yeah I checked that I
think that he had a good closure of his
mind
they're not to get tilted and Sparky
yeah cuz that's that was vain right oh
it's like the do I spark when I wake up
at ha ha combo to get the side switch
[Music]
[Applause]
but gets the super - yeah that is a big
drop confirm off the Bartok is's meter
to kill your brownie badger that is an
unfortunate drops here very unfortunate
one wah-wah
that's the kill
so LK was sparking available but losses
GT Goku and you know he's already got
half life on this character to be fair
though he almost came back with just
Super Saiyan Goku the last game so now
that he has that teen Gohan can spar
game that was so cocky blast and snipe
the jump and they call borrow that says
to cut off the ground after man with an
assist extension that were killed
- overall the vanish big damage on this
parking t go on combos ideal of use of
that there's 50% before knee beaters
fell down
I'm gonna save that meter the combo auto
combo 2h Tatsu my raw age I'm not sure
what happens there so unfortunate for a
fortnight at sparking runs out dead teen
gohan only Super Saiyan Goku remains I
think you can still come back he has
seven bars not a lot of help on to
character so kind of dwindle down at
least one of these to make it less
oppressive against them
yeah honey badgers go clear Bartow for a
bunny characters right it's just this is
this 21 is in a you know a really good
spot I love it and this is gonna set him
up with you know whatever he wants maybe
the fake in the funny end of the Dragon
run go through the jump medium into the
tea blast elicit simcha next dragon rush
that's the kill
and this thing is is that this is now
about even right like LK has way more
life he doesn't have assists of a level
but he's got plenty of meter a Super
Saiyan Goku with meter and that much
help is at rest and he just got the hit
for this class
as level 3 available
Spencer sent it
yeah take as much damage as you can I
mean you know unless attack happens
you're not gonna heal this back yeah I
got a couple pixels here left one for
the double overhead gonna have to be
really careful here as he tries to
regain meter again
dad you're out okay you just can't get
hit fine something like that
drops it that auto combo instead of
confirming a tattoo or something benched
sin paradise backs
barkis's hit but wasn't it rains really
do anything off of there being very
patient here going with the jump back he
danced a lot here thank you by skillful
punch your own self in the chest
buddy now at the solo part aqua with not
a lot of help but a lot of meter to dump
on this I think you got to spend it on
stuff like age Larry vanish or whatever
you need to get the bus rains you should
spend to hear black yeah but he didn't
confirm up that
thought he had the combo home honey
badger I think a couple of those are
just sitting in a way staggers low backs
out of the auto cut up with the auto
combo this is huge you spent three bars
on this oh you bet you he is going into
that bar top level three Lord Knights
still make it out of this whether it's a
level three or he just is able to defend
himself on with this oh it doesn't block
the overhead he couldn't cancel there's
a level one it killed now is so scary
last it'll do it looks for the key
blasts 6m connects now okay with meter
though you can't throw through many of
those you get level three hilarious you
didn't keep it tight lariat Lord Knight
is trying he just needs to find himself
on offense the crowd goes wild honey
badger overlord knife for top sixteenth
losers just like that almost made the
comeback what a clean 2-0 as one of
Puerto Ricans that Puerto Rico's own is
in the top 16 it's the bandana power the
power that was very very very impressive
like especially because I feel like a
lot of a lot of players right when your
team starts to die in that second game
and it comes down to bar Goku I feel
like so many people crack like it's so
easy to just fall apart and be like okay
I think usually
now it's 101 last game starts LK gets a
big hit and it's just like oh god it's
all like crumbling down really quickly
so just stay composed and get the job
done there is not easy even with some
slop some drops and stuff like that it
all worked out in the end so he's moving
on and I think if you're allocated
there's a few moments is you're gonna
look back in that set and just be like
man if I could just clean up these
little things you know any coast along
the other way and you know those little
things matter
you know the context of really pipes
that like that where it's just like last
little hit count I agree and I know
expert there but I definitely think that
one of the disadvantages that out pay
was at the end there was he was
respecting and playing patient too much
there I think that if he would have been
a little bit more aggressive it could be
riskier but I think that that where that
could be where he could have potentially
changed up and thrived at that last two
characters versus each other yeah and
I'm just interested to like you know if
there's a mindset of you know we saw
earlier the trunks came out from LK as
well I wonder if he's still stuck
between two teams where you know he's
not quite comfortable with this squad
yet so still kind of trying to piece it
together and not feeling like okay well
my squad is like 100 percent ready but
I'm just gonna play it and try my best
as we see ray-ray up in the stage gonna
be playing up against our key another PR
player yeah you gotta love you gotta
love seeing ray Rick come back out you
know yeah it's been a while
previous Marvel player right yeah Evo
finalists grand finalists for that game
very talented at fighting games in
general since it losses earlier and you
know looking to get into this top 16
qualifier this is looser side of top 32
for those of you guys curious
oh man empty in the pockets
I've never been and empty the pockets
kind of guy when I play on never I'll
never empty in the pockets
I've never taken all you know some
people take off the bell and do the
pockets take off the watch if your taste
to see if take off the beans that has
never been me I'm like whatever is in my
pockets no problem
I like one of the things I like about
Ray Ray's team that I was watching when
he was playing earlier is that he's
still placed en yeah you know that's
another character that you saw on a lot
of people's teams for a minute and after
the nerves he kind of dropped off you
know it was for a while the kill stage
was like Tim got shotgun you know and
that's where the shotgun kind of became
like a little yeah you know I don't even
say it's that it's still very strong
it's just not as strong as it used to be
right it's like normal eyes now yeah
look he's good but like cheats ego cool
make sense right out to the tangos we
exist as like the same kind of role on
your team for a character so it's like
you know it's a little hard to double
back Hansel from Ray Ray early and yeah
we've seen him some moms put in a lot of
effort I really feel like his tienes
solid but I think his Abbas could do are
excellent and make sense he gets to this
character a really really good that's
really nice to see you again
- you don't
some Aussie players anymore yeah I mean
a year came to go this care for what you
know sparks up this combo yeah he's that
one yeah I mean you're just trying to
really get us through here I mean you
got like one hand spark and I was like
oh yeah
then I came here it's like that
character is really really dangerous
especially when you get the orbs on get
a lot of extensions that you know other
characters don't always have access to
it's really useful
yeah he's solitude he's a very good
character just you know it takes a bit
of effort I think and really optimizing
a lot of the rats that you need both for
block strings and and combos to use the
horns correctly yeah big empty low
starter
I have an ear for meters here for on the
dots and that's part got a block stun
but can't run away from rain to the
corner with that kit blue ball in the
head yeah backed off ball pressure is so
good if you block that assists the
chance of you living a free level one
and that'll do it burns to the sparking
healing so far knock alone with the
level two sparking instead of a little
bit his partner really making quick work
here at Darney yeah first game so far
has looked pretty dominated sparking
runs out Raley gets hit by the six amp
but no I mean nothing after I think
maybe you try to call an assist and he
got like the half circle input when he
did something 20 sides for the most part
you don't kick into arafat much in this
game but there if you chase all time
where that can happen yeah were you like
hauling assists and then you do like a
four foot hole
and you can circle happy one yeah yes we
don't leave it dark he kind of think in
there what can I change up and do here
this was so oppressive especially at the
beginning that first temperature I feel
like your ego a little bit when you get
Tod right off the bat yeah you die okay
okay I got too deep but I'm a spark up
I'll be okay here and then rage still
the sparking character as I cold
here we go again yeah early standing out
drop a half the earth gonna set up
compare that stage and that's a big foot
early
yeah one bar kill Plus built a ton of
meter in that sequence and you know if
Ray gets ahead he's gonna Tod drops it
again that happened in the first game -
yeah and the fly from Ray as well you
gotta watch the fly there were three
cheese cups to grab something
okay guard for the setup here
she go through this comes out and the
fly here yeah you can't challenge with
the super - is that the respect
everybody has to him like he's so fine
the air the mix up on the ground do it
not that scary attacking a kibbutz up
high
yeah so challenge is that that could've
been to H he blasts both players kind of
spacing away from each other trying to
wait for the sophistic um back on deck
we yeah and it's like a dangerous game
because you want to be above kid buu a
lot of cons in the air so you don't get
hit by Q blast and there's mystic ball
or something like that so like you know
if you're [ __ ] you have to think about
that but if you put yourself too high
and just down the ground look for the
stomps of Eli on
yeah and that rock that's gonna get the
hit here with our key
[Music]
logos from the low great feet pendulum
ray-ray
yeah it's blocking it out so far no
panic guard can slow or vanish and the
Garn council finally works out
ciaossu lockdown what's this back now
that was a really important for flight
no ball because otherwise get me stuck a
block something for a long time yeah
100% but he will really get to get off
bottom over there snaps out but you saw
me super fuzzy actually fuzzy attempt
yeah Ron's on their checks on the stand
again not to age
don't break either about there really
love to defense that rare is putting on
but then we just got opened up on a
dragon Ross still doesn't take away from
the fact that he has been blocked like a
champion yeah his even spit great so far
that's been too many things thrown at
him that I think is made of look it's
too uncomfortable banished the van
what are we gonna see here pretty the
fly a little close to try to wrap react
level pretty wobbly and gasps barking
out of the gumball mix-up if your rent
yeah to give your ray-ray
this super jump and then fly is probably
a great idea right because you know that
this character you know Sparky you want
to kind of run it out as much as much as
you can absolutely
there it is it's gone Gannett right away
Reagan say he's gonna have to have side
slit into the corner with four meters
goes right into the level watts and
we're gonna see the TM level three
yeah this character so help you to write
but you might as well spend the meter
Wow
Oh mrs. o'fee hey miss eyre doc on decks
honest use this down gonna go into the
gumball you are locked down sir great
defense though great blocks trades no
confirm up that yeah Andreas love and
Hilo mix up off of a lot of booze mix up
so far we've seen it a lot it's like all
day with eight or whatever in the low
from gumball oh that's honest oh yeah
two
great extensions here from that already
built three bars yeah that hurts that's
like a really rub our council because
all of its the level three at the end
that was very unfortunate and a great
punish there on that we are going to see
a death here Kazama sued yeah you might
as well bring energy to go to do because
you know and keep the sucka got an
answer
light back or anything and twenty one's
gonna go back a little bit yeah that's a
little bit more valuable
yeah Auto combo notices just the jump
super dance which rare is blocked all of
them pretty well Wow mystic ball that's
the kill
where is the interaction they're crazy I
mean he's a sphere 360 degrees he
doesn't care where you are I mean he's a
little Bob man he beats on his chest and
you know clothes seemed out of his head
that's normal wow that was a sick block
below great grief there call out on that
that movement under febrero is really
key to dancing on the other side
jump out and the three-hit air series
right off the ground that should be the
kilian for ray-ray I agree I think he's
gonna close it out here yeah why not
with a TN level three
we know try beam up yeah I think that
was really well played for Mary yet that
one drop on the level three but besides
that I think most of the game is played
really well so that's gonna be top 16
losses for Ray as we're waiting I think
we have two more matches left for 16
qualifiers we have kuba up against
neural arch and then big but Jackson
versus T a wolf is our last match what a
great closer for the night gotta close
at the bud yeah you know when you talk
for a living after like eight hours or
something or ten hours it gets a little
tough is it the real degenerate hours
I mean we're there right like you know
chat room I'm sure you guys I don't know
how long all of you have been watching
put your put put the number in the chat
how many hours or how many minutes of
you and watching the stream so far but
after talking for like six to eight
hours your brain starts to go it's just
sort of natural right if you can only
speak for so long before you start
saying weird stuff and we've hit that
point trust it's that time of nice to
the big but Jackson Puerto Rico's finest
oh boy is he Tebow it's just the
elongated it's the zoom coup but your
band you know who I feel bad for is the
cameraman because the cameraman is I'm
telling are I guess I'll follow this
guide a bit and the finger gun at the
end the finger gun I approve no opponent
I feel like I feel like his true calling
isn't his teammate plays he needs a
plate getting you this man needs to play
getting you talking to nobody
there's like no match to nobody it's
just an empty it's just a bra how do you
have this litter you know what's messed
up is like guaranteed Kubas not slept
like very much either and this is the
kind of energy he's output this the kind
of energy he always outputs at one day
yeah yeah yeah this is like a very
horrible state a couple times oh my god
don't want shake his hand I got the
pleasure playing some casuals earlier
with kuba team his team's fun yeah it's
a very fun explosive team hit is gonna
be a problem if you don't have the
matchup experience against him so if
neural arch is not ready for the hit he
is going to get hit yeah
and also the thing about hit is that his
mix ups are a little non-traditional but
when he does hit you he hurts so bad
this is a very high damage and character
and both of his assists are really
useful for extending so like no matter
where you get like opened up from it's
gonna hurt it was a high damage and
character lots of really good ways to
extend in general his team is very solid
it just needs to get the hit and not be
stuck with Ronis that's basically the
main two things that don't need to have
our pretty standard team on the other
side the GT Goku Goku shell very solid
bar talk to select music he also loves
trunks coupe kuba yeah look at this
stick there's a trunk lever there's a
rust mark on the bottom that where's
hand goes watch where his hand goes his
right hand he's gonna open the stick
watch where his right hand goes it's
blood that's from his palm that's the
rough on the arcade stick from where I
don't think that's true I know he said
he got that from a junkyard I think he
told me he got his stick from a junkyard
I think he just works on a junk car all
right and maybe it's just natural rustic
a from my
look at it it's right where the hand is
you think it's coincidence neural are
having a good start off here we got
another zombies off the screen if he
knows what's good for him he won't let
this hit read and we'll make quick work
of him just to get him out of the way
and not have to deal with yeah you could
have built the rebars you would've been
pretty close to closing man but you know
I think he is one of the hardest
characters in the game for reflect like
you can't be a nation about when you
choose to stop reflecting and you have
to watch the cross depending on if he
commits to stance or no party committed
sin 2 alpha v 2h the Vantage 6n plus
innocence
you know both these SS 4 trunks here are
really solid like both generals yeah but
he's still getting beat up here in the
corner chunks of the corner can be
pretty scary honestly even though shirts
most of the time especially backs up
literally
you know that's Larkin was exactly what
Google on and I think I think the flip
was debated by indicating the to H
anyways Oh what did the other find
success he did not commit there but that
was great
old gets hit by the bug light yeah I
would have liked to see how vanish but
it was at the tail of the sparking so
maybe accession of actually
[Music]
level three heroes a monster bring it
back in he's got spark - oh it's like he
read your mind you might use you he it's
part anyway you're in sync there I don't
even know if that's what you woke up to
I'm smart like I don't even know if
that's what he wanted Ross burger I
don't know where was actually using
Stata zit cream in yeah it just gets hit
by the big jump bass build one meter for
the kill so expect offense
yeah I'm in another be fun
[Music]
probably a snap both the other
characters are pretty unhealthy anyway
yeah no assists yet there's the SIS plus
France bra level three after
I think that's right call I think it
also Park Hills
[Music]
yeah scaling wasn't there really so yeah
out of here
get out of here playing feels kind of
evened up who was sitting on a formal
part on
Larian miss the dragon rush could've
been a snap
pass the stagger because the assist is
on cooldown so you see that my kuba
tried to extend as long as he could so
that hit assist would come back one
level one level threes two things
they're the same that's around your
pocket
he just gets away with keeping his hands
in it's gonna be I'm gonna greet dressed
like this for long time in Canada
perfect gonna shave my head bald he
could be part of the bar both heads you
see the BGC yeah you told me about that
yeah they're my sworn enemies Wow yeah I
think so too and story but spent meters
so Peter penalties on Oh doesn't quite
make it to one bar H stands Cross of
Barnard for the extension
not enough to kill or anything dragon
Russell do it kuba do it work for the
west coast boy oh god I don't know if I
like this you know this is someone who's
almost qualified for the DB FC finals by
the way this is someone who's here to
get points that is a profession for
personal reversible dragon ball player
Cooper cracks me up
[Music]
still left on the planet yeah and you
know all over the place played
racquetball this year too so it's the
cool watch can travel everywhere
actually you know has been really
focused on it this year yeah isn't it
all over the place man he had that great
run at thunderstruck don't keep eyes
bring some black yeah I like the Cooper
waited to see if you is gonna reflect an
attack or something and that is a huge
hit change the future for the bounce age
this is great
got some swag poppers too especially
when you're in the corner with the sword
spins yeah what are you you actually
hurts too is not a little damaging
character especially a little three
hurts I want to say maybe one of the
highest manage for the side swap back
for the corner keep the pressure with
him
yeah I'll take a lot against it in
general because you kind of have to read
it with something or using a sister
cover-up
Oh gets it by that heavy malaria
[Music]
Oh miss with the assist go back both
assist yeah hands go in the pocket any
sparks something get out of that I like
these changes future waiting and then
going in Oh with the reset anyway you
can't take your hands off the stick one
one
yeah on sale anyway there was like a
little bit of help that came back from
the sparking but it ended up mattering
the Chaplin killed anyway yeah yeah try
to make use of what sparking flat yeah
pretty important it's so you better make
use of it that's what characters okay so
this is a lot of damage as much as you
can I thought we might see a spark
sorry Sam to be honest but yeah
Ben's a level 3 instant almost kills
spark needs available very short lip
goes right back to the ground gets thick
and 6m yeah I think barn oxide here yeah
get them out of here go level one into a
level 3 yeah and the reason you do that
there and not just brawl level 3 is
because it's hard to get the term
strawberry right there you have to kind
of use the javelin
change the future right into the
pressure there you are not going to want
to deal with this sir not gonna be quite
enough meter here stays in there with
the key blasts who's been trying to
secure this spot 60 either side spot the
drop you can't either change the future
6m and you can get too much at all scoop
is moving in the top 16 loser to bus
stop oh man from the world tour for this
I miscarried off the stage our trucks
can we have trunks use his level three
and say you need to be stopped
Heaney definitely is based on need to be
stopped Cuba I I feel like if it's like
a bait to shake his hand to because he
goes up there any tabs nine times and
then he reaches to the handshake and
he's never gonna shake your hand it
doesn't matter what you do he's gonna be
silly so there it is you know who I who
do you know we just gave up and threw me
the piece on right there no big but Jack
city walk Jax walks up and hit me with
the peace sign he was like what's good I
got a I got a faint I'm a fan wolf big
but Jackson
two players left see yous gonna qualify
on 516 losers the other matches that we
have coming up we've been talking a
little bit about how that top 16 to
settle we're gonna have Nakia super noon
saves apology man subatomic saver versus
no con me and Chris cheer us as coach
Cowher those are all winter side matches
in case you guys are curious it's gonna
be very interesting know Conover
subatomic sky like East Coast versus
West Coast cuz uh like not the true I
guess deep like New York East Coast but
I think he's a living on North Carolina
I think you're right yeah he's North
Carolina so I not get super noon yes
kill state apology man yeah those are a
battle the coast actually yeah these are
all East versus West and then Chris G
versus watch cows West Coast us versus
the Japan that's East as it gets a loser
site we're gonna have rmz vs. shank so
we're gonna have a euro showdown oh
that's gonna be great yeah Wawa vs. blue
car also is in loser science 16 you need
two matches on the loser side to make it
into top it so I wonder if all the
Europeans are gonna actually have to
plate other I don't know if shanks and
Wawa if they both win or the winner of
the shanks are Z match vs. swallow will
happen but it would be a shame if shanks
and wall would have to play before
coffee yeah cuz that's like those are
the two Europeans to watch out for to
them anyway and to see them and lose a
side playing before top eight will be
pretty pretty crazy yeah
I completely agree but we got wolf we
haven't seen him since this morning yeah
what woman back up here playa Jackson
yeah and that is a pulp fiction shirt on
that I see pretty solid I'm a fan I
think actually Wawa and shanks won't
play for topping from what I'm looking
at here okay
so yeah you don't want to see too many
of them like you still want to see you
know them have a chance and stuff like
yeah without having to play each other
right I do not want to see the Europeans
play each other right I'd want to see
them play against like Japanese players
against like us players PR players I
want to see play each other right into
this final game of our day today got
clipped by the five out and then down
tack into the standing ham screen yeah
Gogeta new character right so I feel a
little bit messing around with them
I think he's pretty solid his commando
is very good and his damage output is
super high there's really really slow
buttons in general like he's not really
gonna challenging a lot of things and
he's just one of those characters that
he's not gonna mix you up that much
right it's to take the road that he's
really gonna catch you with in a full
sprint scenarios
DP on waking up in the farm holds the
van is right now fusions Vegeta or
Vegeta I'm sure everybody in the chat up
their favorite no yet actually that was
great that's um hitting right back I
leave it so far back it extends burstows
I think we're talking earlier yeah yeah
like the Joker he's got the boot and I
know he was the hero the Easton you're
nuts like a locksmith so big booty to
action with the dragon Russia that
doesn't work out got beefy Brawley in
here trying to put the stack super tank
Goku's gonna land them in here this is
looking like me
yeah superdad one here you can take a
level of would go home last I agree with
that it's always smart the level of your
going on and then prove it right you
wanted it right away it's like okay I
got the level but I also have one point
where he's such a dangerous character
with two really solid assists I look for
the roof like all the sword connects
let's back in the corner all gonna take
the snap yeah
bringing Gogeta guys all right looking
for the tape we haven't seen any
commandos yeah that's the one thing that
I've been surprised about that's
something now I think it's very useful
to establish early with the stairs walls
fine
takes a knock-down surprise you usually
see like tacking up reflective really
common often
[Music]
Yeah right there you see that wake up
reflects quite a lot elbow drop one it
is but that's gonna be a dead vegeto big
a bud Jackson the last quarter who can
die here according to the boys hi here
that's right honey badger is Puerto
Ricans they lied to us
yeah you guys how dare you beat me lies
in my ears
it's klesko's fault if you ever CVG
Callisto on twitch don't quit don't
trust that guy to amp to app to app they
just cut the volume from your mic I'm
just a beauty huh my god
hi bro maybe like that Oh No the two
women again but nothing off trying to
reach [ __ ] is 2m goes from the jump
heavy I feel like he's going into it
like every single time with Costa so
it's all event to it yeah better I think
what we'll want little three not sick
the love that was the rough legs and
that should actually be the end of this
character some like j.lo energy right
now it's some JLo energy yes
JLo Jackson I see yes I figured that's
where you were going
yeah I'm a fan call super - at the start
and gets a knock down into the corner
had already interesting perhaps for the
combo star
I really like those strings of uses and
that jump ins just can't have this yeah
beautiful punished because he was
clubbing he insists and like kind of
come in a little too deep for that
standing out that is one of the issues
the playing Fujino right like you have
to commit with the standing out because
it's standing out like once you do it
you're in there forever for life to H is
great and it's big you need to get a hit
there otherwise the sparking is like
really bad right uppercut baby yeah
there's a great punish on that EP there
the tag in to get a little bit of extra
damage not enough to kill with sea level
one so it doesn't stand it for the up
tag there to trying to enter I like that
choice banister vanish the vintage
Spanish always great job there goes
right into the direct rush here
man let's meet her there to kill yeah
it's the one
okay could guard canceled in
he definitely was smart he challenged
their standing in jump cancel knock down
a little bit of an extension it doesn't
have to beat her to kill her anything
cause the pudgy no a cesspool here -
over yeah you know super - feels like a
good option but I guess armor it's a
no-go
yeah when the - true train comes to town
you don't just wanna you want to move
out of the way you don't want to stand
on the tracks definitely not that is a
dangerous characters you super - in
general I think that's a button wolf
that came out of sub-variants
go on again do you have to pray standing
media the long leg of the law that thing
is super good dragon run actually takes
the snap to break 6 m block vanishes out
and no counter vanish to age whip on the
legs put self in the corner yeah finally
a command throw this time the vanish for
the extension has a people says here to
my drop in to go through and a dragon
run doesn't even need the rest of the
call so what what is the what is the
command grab and the other is like yeah
it's like a weird thing it's all based
continents can position - right yeah but
to be honest with you I feel like I
never see it yeah I stick brat it's like
really fast and very far it's like even
like really far away where you're
normalize you just saw a comma
where you would normally expect like a
dragon rush that's where I feel like
people come and throw this character and
it's really hard to deal with you just a
second ago the auto combo I feel like
something that's so good about that is
black pit being an overhead yeah I feel
like if you use it rarely people don't
see it right there's not ready for and
also it's a new pair new son Adrian
it's a little bit faster but it reminds
me a lot of ah we go who's Otto Campos
yeah we're like little a yeah
the train came to town again is lemon
Mikey Brooke if you're a big but Jackson
how deep you spark and that's the
funniest gal it's gonna say you have
sparking so you have to be careful how
you activate a level that is available
this parkings gonna run out in a minute
reflect you have the respect to lariat
after tomorrow and that is a big deal
o reversal level 3 I think it blocks
here yeah
hit about now after six meters available
you got to spend something here I
imagine a little three yeah no court no
for it go for it come on five you don't
get oak yeah there if you spent for it
against Brawly - it's just not big but
Jackson hit him with a nothing personal
kid a teleport to the other side he
likes big but Jackson and he cannot run
the world
oh this guy thank you Marvel players
can't deny makes it into the top 16 so
it's official Big Foot Jackson has made
top 16 at first attack Tenkaichi event
here in Puerto Rico we got the full
bracket set so if you haven't looked
already smash daunt GG you can look up
first tank it's under featured
tournament so you can see the full
bracket yeah we've made it 10 hours
later we've made it to the finish line
you can read right here at noon yeah we
weren't we've been here since noon it's
a quarter past the hair yeah I am sleepy
I'm ready to call it's been a good day
thanks to you guys for all tuning in at
home and enjoying all the Dragon Ball
action thanks to the lovely production
team and everybody that handled this has
been a really really fun first day of
Dragon Ball fighters here and first time
yeah tomorrow we're gonna kick off the
top 16 at noon so right now it is 10
p.m. here right in case you guys are
curious about to turn 10 p.m. so it'll
be noon tomorrow so adjust for your time
zone then the top eight will be
scheduled for 6 p.m. tomorrow but you
know it's tournament standard time so
you never know how it's gonna work right
like it you know it could be 6 p.m. it
could be 8 p.m. you never know so that
should be a lot of fun as well so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the first day
of first attack will be back with top 16
and then later top 8 tomorrow thanks
everybody for watching I'll catch you
guys around so you know